il s'est déjà produit à l'astrolabe avec
un spectacle sur les musiques actuelles
sapritch revient avec chiot une
conférence originale et décalée sur la
culture du rap pickas tous les clichés
et malgré les apparences il sait de quoi
il parle
moi je suis né à la campagne dans un
milieu middle class
je n'ai jamais vendu de drogue et par
dessus tout je suis blanc donc
statistiquement en fait je n'aime pas le
rap regarder ça c'est moi à 17 ans à
travers sa passion sapritch retrace
l'histoire du rap en partant des états
unis dans les années 1960 jusqu'à la
france d'aujourd'hui
loin de lui l'idée de porter un jugement
mais il peut quelquefois être ça
qu'elles s'en tirent sur la place de la
femme dans le rap
alors je vous rassure évidemment la pl
la femme a su trouver sa place dans le
rap c'est la même que d'habitude la
cuisine elles font des gâteaux sur scène
quand je prétends avoir un avis c'est
scénique sais pas c'est pas personnel
j'aimais des avis pour faire va agir les
gens et qu'on réfléchisse tous ensemble
qu'on vibre non mais vos parents ont
tort le rap c'était pas mieux avant
c'est pas vrai le rap c'est mieux
maintenant
bienvenue le rap c'est le rap tu sais
c'est la suisse et la suite du
rock'n'roll ou tout simplement une
quelque part une musique en chasse une
autre
il y a une culture rap aujourd'hui mais
c'est une culture de la contestation à
une et elle vient de la contestation
c'est toujours pareil
déjà dans tout le temps marre des vieux
et les vieux pense que les jeunes sont
des sauvages
alors les jeunes font de la musique de
sauvage et c'est comme ça qu'il
manifeste you de sapritch entre dans le
programme des sessions culturels
scolaires de l'astrolabe sapritch
effectivement on connaissait depuis un
moment on aimait bien la façon qu'il a
d'aborder les choses qui est une
bannière qui n'est pas scolaire du tout
l'idée sécession c'est de proposer des
projets qui parle à la fois aux élèves
mais aussi aux professeurs est
effectivement de trouver comment on peut
proposer un spectacle qu'ils puissent à
la fois servir le court et vous verrez
un peu l'esprit aussi des élèves
d'autres spectacles s'adressent aussi
aux parents et aux enfants comme
box-office un duo qui mélange musique et
human beat box
ils se produiront dimanche 9 décembre à
l'astrolabe